[Music]
welcome back to camera boys everybody it
is another episode of hot seat we have
the hottest seat and the hottest
questions today our lovely guest is big
herc
and to set it off we're gonna have bart
do the coldest of the cold so it's gonna
be that cold dude
what's your favorite brand
of lotion uh
palmer's cocoa butter i got a nice
answer palmer's cocoa butter do you mix
it with another one or you just go
straight palmers man palmer is such a
high grade you can go straight palmers
high quality
the highest
very good absorption rate
it's really good the way you said it
made me want to throw out my jerkins
i was like i gotta write this down i
gotta go consider some of this so big
where did you uh where did you grow up
sacramento california parsley and then
also in the bay area treasure island
wait is that the little island in the
middle i don't know there was people
that lived there yeah nice to be a
military base and before that it was the
world's fair oh yeah and now it's public
housing and i think they're going to
change it into
luxury condos here pretty soon they're
going to make it like uh
yeah it sounds like
[ __ ] it sounds like [ __ ] right there
so would you consider yourself a bay
area nor cal guy uh i would say
northern cali but southern cali's had a
lot of influences on my growth as far as
seeing the world beyond just
sacramento because everybody i've met
from northern california doing i mean
southern california they're doing such
bigger things that all my friends i grew
up with i mean a lot of my friends i
have i have no more more millionaires
that i've met in southern california
than north i know nobody in northern
california is a millionaire so they're
lazier
i'm just kidding
mentality like the sky's the limit in
southern california there's more
entrepreneurial spirit very very much i
mean guys who are just bawling out of
control and there's like they just
origin there's visionaries out here
where's their limit just like 10 feet
they just want a ghost ride whip you
know you know sacramento like
predominantly like good job is working
for the state oh yeah capital right yeah
that's true state government jobs yeah
so that's kind of like where people are
when you start talking about you you're
going to open up some you know
tech or some big maybe um car cup this
and that people like oh man i'm just
going to get a job you work for the
state and get retirement
people don't think like they do more
stability more stability exactly exactly
because i hear people are just more like
i'm going to work for myself build a
business yeah and if and if they just
have a lot more motivation i mean
everybody i've met out here from my my
vietnamese friend you know runs a
mortgage loan company my other friend
lighting company clothing line
um car rental everybody's like they have
all these ideas and just being around
those individuals it makes you want to
hustle harder it makes you want a vision
i mean you know seeing guys like in
their you know 30s 20s driving you know
300 000 cars you will not see nobody
really in sacramento you're not gonna go
to a car show and see you know 20
million worth of cars in the parking lot
i mean that's nothing out here in l.a
you show up i remember going to uh a car
show
in the morning one time um they were
doing a platinum and dude i seen
like some asian cats roll up bro they
were like 12 15 cars deep with lambo the
ferraris what crew was rolling that hard
16 year old chinese boys
dude i've never seen them like i said
dude what do you guys do i have a
clothing line i've never heard of your
clothing
what's your clothing brand i mean you
guys got damn i don't i don't know this
many people would lambor the floor you
know 15 20 deep and then a rolls royce
in front oh you guys are bawling but
it's inspirational because i see that
it's like damn i can go hard sky's the
limit you know you can really go out
here and get it you know people in in
well in particular sacramento the bay
area you have more money a lot of money
in the bay bath's different different
kind of cat you got some guys in the bay
balling but sacramento it's just i felt
like i had outgrown that fishbowl
so you've been in jail right yeah and uh
in jail
what was the craziest
sexual act you saw where it made you go
like this on the inside
you know what never never seen anything
no no direct male
uh homosexuality but i knew of a
situation just through
having other people in the yard tell me
about it there was a big guy who was a
shot caller for the white boys he looked
like tom selleck a big big white boy big
mustache and stuff and uh
and he was kind of like you know calling
the shots on the yard and then this
native american showed up very feminine
you know i had a little haircut and he's
like so so you're oh my god he went and
talked to the warden like what the hell
is going on he's like can you put him in
my cell blah blah blah blah blah blah
and they're like these dudes were lovers
at another institution oh
and it came up nobody knew you know what
i mean because he was running [ __ ] so
when the other white boys like them you
know they didn't want to just do the
savage so they didn't really want to
check a man but they're like do you
can't beat it you know he can't beat our
face no more he can't be our rep he but
he had the native american movement to
sell with him how to clean the cell and
then a dude said himself next door he
said man he'd be in there busting his
cheeks at night
[Laughter]
he said dude you know he'd be up in
there you know lock down whatever you
know he up in there getting it so he
gave up his shot caller position so he
could be in love oh yeah oh [ __ ] what a
forbidden love story that could be a
movie right there dude broke back
uh jail cell jail
and it's like i said this guy he you
know he was one of the big dudes on the
yard man and he gave it up all in the
name of love what are the main like
white bike uh white gangs are they like
more bikers or like uh skinheads or um
you know i think
i don't i mean honestly
i didn't really i guess they had to
click stuff in there they you know they
probably i think in prison
i don't know the fifth and state of
those a b
and then um the skins i think is more on
the street so i don't know what their
clicks are in prison um absolutely area
and brotherhood yeah but you know i i
worked out with a couple big pretty big
white boys when i was in hurlong but
they're from um northern california so
it's like you know they did what they
wanted to do you know it's different
like i said once again northern
california is a different thing and a
lot of people tripped out me working out
with these big white boys but you know
one's from rich man and then one from uh
i want to say like
turlock or something so it wasn't really
a big thing but it wasn't as much in the
feds like i said federal is different
than state state i couldn't come near a
white boy it had been a lot of politics
that's called politicking right where
like it's like you have to stay in your
race and then there's like a pecking
order yeah so you're in federal prison
and that's different from totally
different than state state is it's like
a whole another level federal you're
dealing with guys who
some of them were multi-millionaires man
i mean guys who you know i had a mexican
selling because i was like i said from
up north so i did a different program
and we would you know because they spoke
spanish we we dealt with a lot of
different people so we had
guys from like northern cali we dealt
with sometimes the south fighters would
come to us they're helping with legal
work pisces pisces are people from
mexico from mexico and you know some of
these guys you know they might look like
they're from mexico but these were
balling over there they might this dude
might have been running keith for the
cartel you never know he's working in
the kitchen stealing chicken and [ __ ]
this guy on the street is a millionaire
yes you know but that's his hustle in
there and nobody wants another guy to
know how valuable he is i hope the guy
in there one time with a traffic ticket
and i looked at the ticket i said damn
lamborghini diablo i'm like damn i was
buying you know i've been buying steak
from this dude still in the in the
kitchen so next time i've seen him i'm
like dude yeah he's oh man don't tell
nobody don't tell nobody he said i want
you to know that i'll you know had it
like that so he's playing the gang role
but he didn't want nobody know that he
was pushing a lambo had a you know
harley truck and he was bawling on the
street because then they'll try to get
some from him
so you know a lot of people dumb
themselves down purposely yeah yeah yeah
you know they don't want people you know
tapping in and knowing that you know
what kind of connect you have oh this
dude with a million on the street and
he's acting like he's broken here
yeah
so i know you answered this question so
many times because i've seen so many
people ask you this but is prison rape a
thing
i i didn't see it you know but it does
happen and like if you're a guy that
shows feminine tendencies
and
you know one of the biggest things is
like when you go to laundry to get your
clothing you're not going to have them
you know you're not going to wear no
two two sizes too small pants if you're
walking around with some tight-ass pants
[ __ ] oh that's like you you're
sex playing them yeah so you're letting
dudes know that i'm i'm i'm showing
cheeks i'm showing cheeks
you're not you're if you're doing that
they're like damn you got some tight-ass
pants on and dude they'll um you know
they'll they'll they'll act on that man
you know dude told me one time you know
he's seen a dude up in there real soft i
don't know if he's in there for like a
credit card you know credit card credit
some [ __ ] drives
predominantly
a crime committed by gay people you know
not
not stereotyping but it is so they'll
assume if you're very articulate you're
you know you carry yourself certain way
you did a credit card crime you know
that's a non-violent high-level crime
but it's like fraud and stuff like that
maybe you were gay so those guys they
have a tendency to like think oh if this
guy did that maybe he's soft i can play
him but he in my boat my guy was telling
me that another institution he was that
you know they've seen the guy walk
around tight pants and they see that for
a little while you know they'll have a
couple guys no they'll like gang up you
know he said they gained up on a dude at
one of the usps and you know they put a
knife on them and they poked them enough
to where they they made them kind of
hurt and they went in there raped them
and that's what some of these dudes do
but those are like rat pack dudes know
the predators and i don't know what
particular demographic these guys were
from but he said that you know it was
brothers on brothers and they got one
dude in there and they you know these
dudes raped another dude unfortunately i
never seen any of that happen personally
where i was at
as far as anybody get forcibly raped and
i would imagine more in the state
because of the mentality that it
happened more often but i didn't witness
it in the fed thank god when a dude
bones another dude
but then says he's not gay how do you
explain that there is no explanation to
that
i knew it yeah today's video is brought
to you by tushy okay so i just moved in
to my new place in las vegas shout outs
for tushy for giving me my very own
bidet and you know i put off installing
it for quite some time because you know
when you're moving you have a lot of
things in boxes but what i realized is i
was using a ton of toilet paper like i
don't use this much toilet paper what
the hell is happening and what i found
out is because
tushy is so eco-friendly you know when
you use the bidet to wash your booty
hole you just have to pat it dry with
tissue and you don't even have to keep
wiping and wiping and wiping and using
the whole dang roll and so i didn't
realize how much money i was saving it
was pretty pretty crazy what i found out
is i'm very very lazy because all of
this installs in eight minutes i could
have got this done real quick i did it
before i don't know it's been so long
that i forgot to do it but if you start
using this you save about eighty percent
of your tissue paper use okay that's a
lot if you're going to get rolls and
rolls and rolls like
man you're shaving down that cost to
like very little money and you know that
this is a good thing because i've been
using it for at least five years now and
i brought it from my la house all the
way to my vegas house and tushy has now
cleaned over one million happy bums so i
want all of our listeners to have clean
bums visit hellotushy.com
off the record to get 10 off and free
shipping right now tag us and at
hellotushy on social media so we could
celebrate your clean butt with you
that's hellotushy.com
off the record for ten percent off okay
somebody say somebody say prison gay or
something like that or i've never seen
that because i know guys who are doing
like life for 30 years and they never
yeah you know
cut off like they were gonna [ __ ] a guy
to kind of pass their time or because
they can control a structure or your
sexual urge man if you're a human being
you have you can control that that's
like walking around down the street
and you can't control i can control i
can't control you know i mean come on
bro you're a man you got to have some
type of willpower and that shouldn't be
your main drive for existence so if
you're in prison you're saying you're
going to be having sexual relations with
men then that's something that was
already a proclivity that was in you on
the street and you just acted on it now
and you're trying to justify it so you
did ten years you said eight years eight
months what was the um hardest thing to
that you missed when you're in there um
being around women like the free will of
being around women and and and then um
probably like conversation good people
conversation
because the the energy in there and you
know people think all the physical part
well when you start listening and you
start realizing the conversation and who
you're talking to you realize like man
i'm not liking people
you know and i'm not trying to sound
like oh i'm all that but
i just knew that
i had not really paid attention to my
value system
and what i really
considered um
things i i looked up to in life
compared to other people when i started
listening to other people talk and how
they carried on what they
what they glorize it was it wasn't me
you know and that was the hardest part
but you have to
kind of
pretend to a degree because you want to
seem like you're too better because you
feel like you're better and then you
know oh you're better than us and we're
going to take you out you know so a lot
of guys had that sense too where they
think oh man you don't hang out with us
what makes you any better than us you're
in here with us so why don't you do time
like we're doing time and so you have
people like that who are hating on you
because you are doing things that better
yourself you know how you're like trying
to pursue a spirituality a little bit
more by reading books and stuff you ever
like look in other cells and see people
doing yoga and stuff uh never seen
anybody doing yoga but i you know had
guys that associated life socialized
with that we learned to meditate like i
was able to have a out of body
experience in there that's where i
learned deep meditation how to like
quiet the thoughts of my head and to
tune in with just like nothingness to
kind of leave my body in like almost
like an astrophysical sense imagine if
you get charged with escaping because of
that
[Laughter]
he's not even here
bring it back
get back in there
he's across the street at the mcdonald's
feels good to be free
so you were talking about earlier you
didn't mess with a lot of people because
you were like i'm trying to stay away
from trouble
how would you do that day to day because
i imagine it's so hard to like
you know you're rubbing elbows with
these dudes all the time how would you
stay away from that i tried to have a
program where i got up and i kind of
went and did like my little routine
where i went um i went and worked out in
the mornings and kind of did my
exercising and stuff and i had a guy
worked out with my male mentor the black
brother i would work with him and then
after lunch i'd come back and then the
white mentor i would work with him on
law studying law helping people and that
would keep me going and then maybe
sometimes in the evening i would go and
walk the track for an hour so just to
kind of clear my mind so i had a program
i didn't really give myself any free
time see when you have too much free
time and you're just hanging out and you
got guys you want to sit down and start
saying hey come on come talk to me and
then that's how you get caught up and
the thing is i always call it the tar
baby where once you start hanging out
with something and you get some tar in
your hands it's hard to get it off
because now you've done open that door
and then we try to close it they're like
oh man why don't you come hanging out
you were kind of the other day and it's
like oh now you're too good blah blah
blah now they start hating on you like
oh he's in a lot he's hanging out there
dude he thinks he's better than us see
man blah blah blah so they start
creating this whole
this whole story in their mind on why
they don't want to like you no more but
if you never open that door you don't
have to worry about that so you got to
be cautious of that when you start
letting people into your circle
especially when you're trying to do
certain things and it doesn't align with
these other people's agendas so i always
try to keep it to a minimal and on top
of that because i was in a law library
and doing things of that nature it kind
of made myself a commodity because i
could help people i could type i can
help people look up stuff a lot of these
guys aren't very educated book wise so i
knew how to apply a lot of that stuff so
that was like my angle and my whole
hustle in prison was helping people with
the law what was it like getting out
because you did eight years you said
yeah yeah so was it was it weird to kind
of see
from where you went in like the world
after you got out is like kind of
changed um well to be honest with you
because the whole time i was in there i
didn't want to become institutionalized
so i always said in my mind i'm just
passing through so i would fantasize
about okay what if they call me to r d
today or i was always filing something
in prison to try to get out early so i'm
like man they call me next week i'll be
in the hemis i'm gonna buy this car i'm
gonna go over here i'm gonna move over
here to cover i'm gonna move to marina
to ray get this be just discussed it's
partly by the beast so i was always
creating these fantasies in my mind so i
never was really in prison i was there
being detained but i was never calling
myself an inmate or convict so it was
crazy the day i got out it was almost
like i had been in a just like almost
like a um
like a chamber like a time chamber it's
almost like that movie with demolition
man where i got out wow because i've
never programmed the prison you know i
never adapted now i have nightmares
because i'm like man i'm like you know
i'm still in prison i don't know i can't
figure out how to get out but
mentally i never
consider myself institutionalized or in
prison so when i got out the transition
was just a matter of me instantly
hustling like i always i already said
like i'm going to get out here i'm not
going to get a job i'm going to figure
out a way to you know become a producer
i'm going to produce i know do my book i
wrote three books in prison you know i
worked on different like movie ideas so
that was my whole goal and i never
deviated from that so the transition was
easier for me than some people because
i've seen some people in halfway house
and they got out and you see them
they're walking around they're going to
the career center and they're just like
dude you can see they're defeated they
might even want to go back in huh cause
you're so used to it so they're already
programmed and because they have like oh
the only thing saving a lot of those
guys is their baby mama or maybe their
mom or somebody you see for myself
i i didn't go back to anybody i came
back out to la but i didn't fall into
anybody really helping me i just created
my own stuff so i didn't have any visits
or anything so my mentality was i'm
gonna show people that i'm not a piece
of [ __ ]
that i made bad choices but i'm better
than this and when i bounce back i'ma
show people that i'm the truth so that
was my whole thing and not like allowing
the system to
dictate to me who i'm going to become
after that regardless of having i had
three felonies at that point how are you
able to do that because that eight years
is such a long time like that's like
that's so strong of a will i just dude i
every day i just really i i meditated
and i spoke to the universe to try to
ask for strength and to try to guide me
on what my purpose is
and what my true calling is because i
know it wasn't being in prison yeah you
know i know it wasn't um so just like a
daily thing daily thing i would just say
these mantras sometimes i'd read these
different things as far as like empower
myself i remember one time i had these
two sellies man i had a super [ __ ] and a
super blood
and i mean they were just tell stories
about this robbery mayhem just doing
stuff and i'm like dang you know god
what is this what is this what is this
supposed to mean what's this lesson you
know just negative and you can see him
like he'll be laying there and i'm
reading my book and the three men
selling they'd be looking at me
like the [ __ ] think he you know
reading the book who the [ __ ] you think
he is you know dude i see i can feel it
the tension and you know i i always felt
like at some point i thought i was gonna
have to do something like they're gonna
try to stab me i have to stab this dude
just because you're reading a book just
because i'm not engaging oh i'm not i'm
not talking i'm not i'm not buying into
it makes them insecure yeah i think i'm
you know like i think i'm better because
i'm not i'm not doing the same thing
they're doing which that's what they're
these guys are already they're like it's
almost like demons you know and i'm
trying to fight the demons i'm trying to
stay strong but this is a challenge
almost a spiritual battle prison is a
spiritual thing too gets a lot of energy
wars going on people trying to pull you
dark side so if i started doing it so my
thing is how i got to prison was because
i kept
entertaining these negative thoughts
these negative vibrations so in order to
reverse that when i was laying on the
beach i said i gotta stop i stop right
there and it's like you know you ever
seen that big blade spinning and it you
throw something in there to shred it i
had to stop that with so much
centrifugal force and to reverse it to
get it going where it created momentum i
had to practice that daily and so i
could never let myself fall back into
telling war stories or glories and crime
or entertaining violence i had to work
hard to not even i don't want to talk
about that stuff that's what got me
there because there's a lot of talk
about like are prisons really
rehabilitative or anything like that do
you have a i guess like a
uh
a thing that you feel like would help
other people or do you do you have not
not that you would have an answer but
like is there something that you feel
might help other people like find that
place or is that just a very personal
journey that they all have to go through
it's a personal journey but before you
even go to prison you need to
if it's putting yourself around a
environment that's conducive for you to
grow
as a being not only materially which
everybody's caught up on material the
watch the the card the girl i'm talking
about as a spiritual person to find
purpose and meaning just because you
have a lot of money that means you have
purpose in me you have a lot of money
but if you acquired it through ill god
means then the energy with that is
it can it can attract a whole nother
thing that can result in you losing your
life even though you have a bunch of it
so you have to focus on your your soul
your social circle and what you put out
into the world as far as what you want
to attract i was in just a bad social
circle when i was before i committed to
bank robbery i didn't really understand
really what my ultimate goal was or my
purpose was i had you know mingled in
different circles but with no real
direction because i didn't know who i
was or where i was going so as far as
people and when you get to prison it's
so much more clicked up and then you
can't leave then it's harder so you have
to fight even harder to find your
identity most people have no identity
all they do they see something they um
like this and they follow this or they
join this and they don't create their
own identity and then you're taught a
false identity because most of [ __ ]
we're talking school is [ __ ] when
you start researching the history and
the lies and all the stuff so you're
fighting three different angles of just
negative
affirmations to become who you are so
it's hard and they know that they said
it like that up on purpose and that's
why it's easy to control everybody
because nobody has any identity they
don't know where they're going we have
the program school teach you to go
school programs whole different prison
program get up go to work
go lunch go to break go home sleep
retire you know it's the same [ __ ]
go go to school graduate get a job work
30 years retire die
same [ __ ] where's the breakup where is
your identity at you you went to a job
but you might have been the greatest
violinist that ever lived you might have
been one of the most inventive you know
minds we've had but because you didn't
ever get a chance to find who you are
you never got to explore that side of
yourself which you left humanity
avoiding humanity you you were here for
a purpose and i just sit around like my
purpose has got to be greater than
sitting in the cell this is crazy i walk
the yard i'm like damn and this is crazy
and some dudes in there they're just
oblivious they're walking around and you
feel the energy you're like oh my god
it's like groundhog day every day like
this dude this is this is not normal
it's not normal the guards in there
they're working i'm getting a paycheck
dude it's not normal to get a paycheck
like this
it's not normal so i just used to have
to really sit around and i used to just
get in my own head and just go back and
just think like damn when did it start
when i stole those pair of shoes god
damn it i should've never
but you got to face all that stuff right
you're going to sit down but it's
painful a lot of people don't want to
face that because then you start going
backwards and start going backwards and
and looking at everything you've done
and how it led up you don't wake up one
day and say hey i'm going to rob a bank
yeah take over a bank
you got to work up to that so it's like
it's a whole deprogramming reprogramming
process where's a good place to start
with that like where do you where do you
look to i guess to even start that
journey i would say i would look at your
values and ask yourself are these your
values or these values somebody else's
values that you
adopted i think most people got others
yeah
yeah their parents all that [ __ ] be
honest man as i got older i thought man
am i adopted
but i said damn my mom had me at 14 i
couldn't have been that young but
adopted because i think so much
differently i look at my family man i'm
a health freak i have ambition i'm like
i boy i'm like a really like animated
person and everybody else is just kind
of like chill oh you know just
not very kind of lackluster not super
goal orientated or driven i'm like the
type of dude like when i put my mind at
something i'll die for it i'm gonna die
you know i mean i'll die for it so why
not die for something good but my that's
the type of mentality i have is all or
nothing i don't do stuff with a backup
plan ah i'm gonna do this and if i don't
make it i can go back and become a trash
man i don't think about that [ __ ] ain't
no backup it's all or nothing especially
with something positive because i feel
like i was put here if you truly believe
in yourself and who you are then the
universe is going to make a way for you
to be that which you are but if you get
a universe and out because you don't
really believe in that then the universe
is going to give you easier out
that's how the universe works if you
want to be the highest every anybody
before they actually hit major success
they've had a really depressing moment
or felt like man is this really all
worth it it's like child birth oh my god
it hurts so bad is it really worth it to
have this little baby little baby
but then the baby comes like oh baby
you're so beautiful
[Music]
you